يوم الجمعه احيا فنان العرب محمد عبده حفل
غنائي استثنائي ضمن فعاليات مهرجان ليالي
البتراء الورديه اللي بيقام في القريه
التراثيه في مدينه البتراء في الاردن
الحفل اقيم في مكان حقيقه ساحر وفي جو
رائع وغنى ابو نوره امام الالاف من الحضور
على مدار ساعتين ونصف اجمل اغاني بمشاركه
اكثر من 50 موسيقي وقياده المايسترو هاني
فرحات وكامير العربيه كانت موجوده هناك
فنان العرب ماذا يقول في هذه الاجواء
وماذا يقول عن هذا الحفل الاول في مدينه
البتراء وهنا في المدينه الورديه اتمنى
انها تكون ليله ورديه ايضا
والليله احنا في جو جميل جدا
حلوه جميله اتمنى ان شاء الله كل العرب
يجوا يشوفوهم تتطور المنطقه فانت تتطور
الى مدينه سياحيه عالميه يعني ان شاء الله
[موسيقى]
عيناك
غابتا نخيل
ساعه السحر او شرفه مميزات الشعب الاردني
الجميل انه ملتفن الحور قيادته بوفاء
وباخلاص هذا شيء عظيم جدا لا يؤاتيه الا
شعب في المملكه العربيه السعوديه
[موسيقى]
[تصفيق]
يا بنت
[موسيقى]
النور
يا بدايات المحبه ويا نهايات الولد
الحسن سبحان ربك ظالم وما اعدله فعادكم
[موسيقى]
الله
يكون
كل العاش
[موسيقى]